[Music]
et is looking back at two of the biggest
celebrity splits of 2016 taylor swift
and calvin harris and brad pitt and
angelina jolie
[Music]
what is the best gift you've ever
received my boyfriend planted a an olive
tree in my yard for Christmas
me
hey Gary Calvin shared so many memories
during their 14-month romance for the
first time I had the most amazing person
to come home to when the spotlight went
out and when the crowds were all gone so
um I want to thank my boyfriend for that
and the split seemed pretty civil when
Calvin tweeted quote the only truth here
is that a relationship came to an end
and what remains is a huge amount of
love and respect then this happened just
two weeks later tater was snapped on a
beach making out with actor Tom
Hiddleston they were caught on camera
dancing together at the Met bald just
one month before Tom even wore t-shirt
which red eye heart TS at a big fourth
of july party at taylor's house then a
jab at her ex a few weeks later taylor
dropped a bombshell she confirmed rumors
that she secretly wrote Calvin's hit
song this is what you came for hood was
reported by Rihanna Calvin responded
that Taylor had wanted to keep the
project secret tweeting quote I figure
if you're happy in your new relationship
you should focus on that instead of
trying to tear your ex-bf down for
something to do as for tater and Tom
well that too came to an end the
whirlwind romance plastic for three
months there was one split this year
that completely overshadow Taylor and
her man and I'm talking of course about
Brad and Angelina it was the biggest
celebrity breakup in decades and it was
made even worse by a child abuse
investigation we loved him every day for
all the things he does and for being a
great father and a great man Brad and
Angie sure didn't look like a couple
heading for divorce this was their last
big appearance together upbeat and
glamorous on the red carpet just over a
year ago at the opening night gala
premiere of by to see how was it the gym
you get married happiest time of your
life and then all of a sudden you go up
and do this darkly a couple on the brink
of disaster yeah yeah right how crazy
with that yeah it was good it was really
good it's good time and you know we came
out stronger on the other end but in
September Brad and Angie went from an
a-list couple to battling access
Angelina filed divorce papers citing
irreconcilable differences the split
took a startling turn when it was
revealed that pit was being investigated
for child abuse
allegations after some type of incident
with Pitt and his kids Brad denied the
allegations and last month he was
cleared of any wrongdoing at this point
Angelina has primary physical custody of
all six children brad has filed for
joint custody but has agreed to a
temporary arrangement for his visits are
monitored so what is next well earlier
this month we asked Angelina's attorney
Laura Wasser my hope is that with the
upcoming holidays things will come down
a little bit will they be together for
the holidays I don't believe so
[Music]
you